war is a nasty business you want to
maximize your highest percentage chance
of being able to make it home in one
piece
that's an offense what you just said
right there who is the biggest threat we
have today us we will screw ourselves
over far before anybody else does so
what's your concern trying to prove that
women can do certain things or
transgenders can fit into certain
elements everybody's being affected by
politically correctness the only way
that I really see that being lifted off
of our society is a huge kick in the
nuts Wow like licking a Chinese doorknob
in terms of safety right now it's gas
station sushi right it's not in your
favor that it's gonna pan out I came
here to get away from the craziness I
know you're right an effect of an on a
deployment to Iraq there was a group of
Marines in the area that we were in and
they had an explosive detector dogs I
mean that was where everything kind of
clicked even dogs can sometimes
experience PTSD absolutely you really
believe that I know that your favorite
want to train for war for military if
you're looking to hire somebody if
you're gonna interview them you're gonna
see what a skillset is how do you
interview dog good my wife wants a Chow
Chow dog sorry I hear that I love Chows
I love all dogs you're not doing you or
the dog any favors by adopting the wrong
dog but how big is the dog breeding
business this number should scare
everybody does that mean that you kill
them no not necessarily
so if there is such a thing as I have
anything that's filled with dogs god I
hope so
did you ever think you would make it
take sweet victory I know this slice
mill for
yeah yeah why would you bet on Goliath
well we got red tape now you came in
given values contagious this world of
entrepreneurs we can evaluate a haters
happy run homie look what I become I'm
the one
[Music]
my guest today is a three-time New York
Times best seller and he's a former Navy
SEAL and on top of that he's a dog
behaviorist we've already been chatting
it up on many different topics I said
let's just turn on the camera let's get
right into it very very interesting cat
Mike Ritland thank you for coming out
being a guest on that tainment no thanks
for having me it's a pleasure to be here
it's good to have you man thank you for
your service
no it's it's an honor to be in a place
to be able to serve so I appreciate it
it's greif feel the same way as well but
for you you went to Navy SEALs like I
was just the soldier a specialist in the
hunter force airborne you became a Navy
so at what point that you know you
wanted to be a Navy SEAL I read a
Popular Mechanics article in high school
when I was a I want to say about a
sophomore and I had grown up swimming
and for me it was kind of the
culmination of everything it was the
ability to get in trouble but but get
away with it and be paid to do it in
conjunction with kind of focusing on the
maritime aspect which is what I was the
most comfortable with so for me it just
seemed you know reading and I was like
that's it this is what I need to be
doing and so from that day forward I
spent the whole rest of high school
basically preparing myself as best I
could to you know to try to do that for
a living and so I waited high school at
17 had to wait until I turned 18 to to
actually go to boot camp and then showed
up and try it out and went straight to
bud so straight to buds yeah well I went
to a school for four months got
intelligence specialist which at that
time I had to but I already had to go to
some a school but yeah right after that
I went when I was I was in buds at 18
how old were you when you knew you
wanted to be a navy so when you read
that about 15 all right 15 yeah so pre
15 you're not you're undecided no and I
guess ironically enough I remember being
in junior high during the first Gulf War
and being just honestly scared scared to
death that our country was going to war
and and being afraid that you know what
if I get drafted like what if this is
still going on when I turn II really
like I was I was actually scared of it
at seventh grade but just a few years
later if that doesn't speak to maturity
that the testosterone brings as a
as a pubescent teenager that you know my
my role in ideology towards that change
dramatically so yeah as soon as I had
about 15 I wanted to do something both
my grandparents were in World War two
and I was just very inspired by that so
something for me now that I just I kind
of grew up or grew into wanting to do as
I became a young man what would they
tell you stories would you sit down and
want to hear stories like we did
gravitate towards it from a young age I
absolutely did my mom's dad was in the
Navy he was on a minesweeper in a fleet
of 98 of them that were in the Med and
only two of them returned 96 of the 98
were either sunk or partially sunk or
you know disabled enough to not make it
back and he had just he was a cook you
know which was kind of an interesting
change of pace I guess from what I
wanted to do but but just yeah his
stories about pulling into port and and
being at war in the Mediterranean in the
world in world war 2 was was really
inspiring my dad's dad was in the army
he was on the German front and actually
got got discharged from the Army for
getting in a bar fight and beating a
fellow allied soldiers an English
soldier actually beat him to death and
in a bar fight and so they sent him home
which that doesn't tell you how how much
time has changed her times have changed
and that now you'd go to prison for the
rest he was in prison Photovoice was
life today yeah it's pretty much what do
you think about it what time what makes
more sense though to me in in this grand
scope of warfare which is ultimately
what our military is is poised for I
think it should go far back to the old
school oh really
no the days of hazing and obviously
there is a happy medium I think you can
for sure overdo it back then I think
that's probably a little a little too
far back but you know I know the
difference between say when I was you
know coming in in the early or the late
90s rather as an early frogman versus
how it is now it's vastly different in
terms of our ability to kind of police
our own I think especially in the
military that that is a necessary I
wouldn't call it an evil but just a
necessary augmentation to
units being able to keep themselves
sharp honest and you know and then have
the right guys doing the the right job
for the right reasons now I think that a
lot of guys do it to check that box and
wear the t-shirt and say that they did
it and when it comes time to do
warriorship so to speak
they don't want to have any part of it
you know and I think that that's a huge
problem interesting then it reflects in
in a lot of what's going on in the
community nowadays I think in the
community of seal buds as would you yes
I'd say all of Special Operations and I
would even say broad spectrum to the to
the entire US military I think that
there there is a problem with it being
geared more towards a social experiment
I think the last presidential
administration had had some negative
impacts that way I don't think what our
society reflects in terms of you know
how we we view certain hotbed issues
that are pretty polarizing I don't
believe that it suits our military's
best interests to meddle in those
affairs whatsoever you know to me I like
to reduce it down and keep it really
simple because it is simple is that the
United States military has one job and
that's to go over overseas and break
stuff and kill people in the event of
them needing to do so and every decision
should be boiled down to does it make us
a more effective war fighting force or
does it not if it does then you should
do it irrespective of cost irrespective
of social heartburn that it might create
an irrespective of really anything other
than that singular goal of is just what
we're here to do or not and it really
needs to stay that simple
is it is it that black and white to you
it is because it's it's a unlike really
every other aspect of our life we're
very few other ones it's a a mission or
purpose built you know element where
everything you do revolves around your
ability to to go places and be effective
in terms of a war fighting force you
know so whether or not women should be
in certain roles or transgender should
be allowed or any of those things you
know to me that I'm reminded of a the
Jeff Goldblum quote in Jurassic Park
which is where he says we've spent so
much time thinking about
they're not we could or couldn't we
never stop to think whether or not we
should or shouldn't and in relation to
you know pulling the DNA out of a
mosquito in amber or whatever and to me
it's very much that way is that trying
to prove that women can do certain
things or that transgenders can fit into
certain elements to me I think misses
the boat is that it you know to me that
that's not the place to do that if you
want to have a an experiment that way
then do it in the Olympics do it in
collegiate sports first you know if you
want to try something out try it there
where people's lives aren't on the line
because if you'll notice you know
there's a pretty stark contrast between
men and women and competition as it
relates at a world-class level well in
the military and especially in Special
Operations it's absolutely no different
there is a huge disparity between sexes
when it comes to combative everything
take the UFC as an example you know
there's a reason there's men's and men
and women's competition classes where
why is there not a push to make that
co-ed there's not why isn't there why is
there a push to have women Navy SEALs
and women Rangers in Green Berets but
nobody gives a [ __ ] to have a 155 pound
woman face Conor McGregor in the ring
why not what why is there not that the
same level of bordering on vitriol for
for that competitive equality that
exists when when the reality of it is is
whether you take the Olympics or the UFC
is that everybody knows what what the
actual result would be and that would be
an outclassing and and I think very few
if any women would win anything and then
that's why there are women's divisions
in both the Olympics collegiate sports
as well as thirdly being the UFC dad
that led to two different parts what
part of that you think is the guy at the
top who runs UFC because there's no way
in the world he's gonna tolerate that
you know what I'm saying where he's he's
not a personality that is like well I
think it's fair we have to be fair and
what about this and people's feelings
how much everything has to do with them
and how much of it has to do with media
pressure and organizations to want to
get to that point you have see specific
unquestionably that's a factor however
there's no media pressure for that why
isn't there why is there so much media
pressure on female seals Green Berets
Rangers
cetera absolutely zero when it comes to
why aren't there just Olympic events why
are there male/female there's no
heartburn with that so UFC yeah you
could say Dana white maybe has the
personality that would make it bordering
on impossible to do that anyway but
there's not even the effort to make that
happen
on the other hand there's also a number
of other competitive or combative sports
leagues there's Bellator there's a bunch
of smaller ones where there's absolutely
no push for that either and again I
would say collegiate sports zero there's
crickets why is there an LPGA why is
there a WNBA why is there not a push to
have all of these women who play in
those leagues play in the NBA and
mandate that there's a 50/50 percentage
or a 60/40 or whatever the population is
to reflect that there's absolutely none
why not to me
the fact that they're there is such
pushback and such you know
aggressiveness when it comes to proving
that women can do certain things I have
no doubt that there are some women out
there that can physically do certain
things that that any man can do there's
there's you can watch a CrossFit
competition and see that for sure there
are some that could probably make it
through my point is is that from from a
warfighting effectiveness standpoint it
doesn't matter you know and the reason
it doesn't matter is because when you
interject different sexes into those
types of roles it causes problems my
idea or fix or whatever not that I'm
individual and thinking this there's a
number of us that do is I would say just
have female Special Operations units
that are all female the same way Israel
has has had actually enormous success
with you know there doesn't need to be
female seals there could be female
whatever you know special operations
detachment or unit that you want to
stand up from scratch and have it be all
women I've got no problem with that
there there are a number of applications
where women I think are better suited
than men and insert and especially
covert operations where women especially
in certain parts of the Middle East that
you can relate to where women have far
more access and far less microscope on
them in terms of getting into certain
areas for
is not because their women are going to
be given a pass I'm not saying that they
shouldn't you know have a role in combat
I think I think well for for starters
they already do which I am NOT going to
get into any further than that but
there's there's no shortage of women
that are already doing things that most
people never hear about that you know
that are absolutely beneficial and
worthwhile and should be applauded
however in my opinion and I can say
ninety eight point nine percent of all
of their special operators opinions out
there former or active mirrors that same
thing so let me ask you this so you're
not saying no to women getting into
Special Operations you're talking about
separate the two and they're able to go
in a different direction than maybe the
men are going so right now when you went
to Budds was it all men when you went to
Butz because you went buzz what year it
was a 97 97 so you are you in high
school class of 96 or 97 96 96 so we're
the same year I'm also class of 96 yeah
so graduate 96 then you go to buds in 97
there are no women in your class at all
97 correct how about today to my
knowledge there still hasn't been any
women that have actually classed up
there's been a couple that have tried
and have either failed or quit in the in
the pre training phase which is at Great
Lakes now which is you know in Great
Lakes Illinois just just after boot camp
there's a like a couple month pre
training period that is supposed to get
prospective students ready to to be a
little a little better prepared for buds
but not none of them to my knowledge
have made it past that so what's your
concern what's your concern since it's
not I guess it hasn't happened yet my
concern is the principle of it is is the
push to to make that Avenue available
when when that very simple question of
does this make us a more effective war
fighting force in my opinion no it
doesn't in my opinion it causes far more
problems and so I I do think it is that
black and white when it comes to your
mission is very black and white you can
reduce those decisions in terms of
whether or not it makes us at a higher
capacity or not very black and white
interesting when you think GI Jane is
more of a Hollywood story and not more
of a
life-story it's a hundred percent more
of a Hollywood story yeah you know again
I I have seen some women in some
capacities that I think physically could
probably make it through training not
not more than probably that I could
count on one hand but my point is is
that even if let's let's say there was
just being liberal about it let's say
there was 20 women a year that had the
all of the the different genetic traits
and drive and physical attributes
required to make it through training
those those 20 females in terms of their
addition to the community in my opinion
are going to far outweigh in a negative
manner the the warfighting efficacy of
those units because they're women
involved like wow you really believe
that I know that you know that I know
that and how many of your peers would
you say think the same way as you do I
don't know a single one that doesn't oh
okay through the 98.9 making the
assumption that there's probably a few
people out there that you know have been
out for you know long enough and think
you know yeah hey that's great but I can
tell you overwhelmingly every everybody
that I know and have talked to has the
exact same opinion about it being
overseas in a Forward Operating Base
it's one thing to make it through
training where there's a safety net and
there's a mental safety net where
everybody that goes to training no
matter how hard and how rough it gets
you have a a primal understanding that
at the end of the day it's the end of
the day you know and that your life
isn't really on the line whereas when
you are in a Forward Operating Base and
and everything is on the the chaos is
literally brimming day-in day-out that
was a very very different mindset so
let's just say you were you went to what
operation you went on a few operations
give me one of them just someone in
particular was the the oil platforms
that were about 25 miles off the coast
in the northern Arabian Gulf but 25
miles south off the coast of Basra and
are in southern Iraq got it there were a
number of oil platforms that my platoon
from SEAL team three as well as another
platoon from a different team took these
oil rigs down over the course of about
six and a half hours there was about
thirty of us and we captured 20
three I believe Iraqi prisoners of war
secured the whole the whole oil platform
took it down and by sunset had it had it
secured and had them had them bagged up
in tents yeah here's a question what if
one of those 20 that you said per your
king graduate buds was a scientific part
of your unit who would you feel
comfortable taking that you know
assignment then going there with another
woman part of your team on the actions
at the objective yes doing the actual
person yeah I would okay if they
physically and mentally happen and this
is assuming and taking for granted that
no standards have been changed and from
my perspective than no standards being
changed are there aren't there aren't
female locker rooms there aren't female
berthing spaces there aren't um so you
know you have your period so you're not
going in the ocean this evening there's
none of that you are treated absolutely
no different there's no accommodations
made what what I think though is is
leading up until that point if I if I
look back and think of the amount of
time that we spent getting ready to do
that and then in the close quarters
living and the things that we went
through as a platoon together to get
ready for that I don't think a woman
would have been a value added asset in a
platoon at that point I think it would
have caused more harm than good for that
assignment for that's specific for any
of them you know any of them for any of
them okay because the the thing that's
important to realize is that your time
in a platoon is you know for those I
mean you you understand it more than
most I think because of your time at the
hundred and first is that you know that
that ability to to separate yourself
from the entire planet basically from
your family from your friends from
everybody and you're out in these super
isolated areas doing really dangerous
stuff day in day out it creates a bond
with each other that that exists
differently I think than any other
aspect of our society and it's it's hard
to explain it but what I can say is that
when we're in forward operating bases
and let's say for example there's an
intelligence representative that happens
to be a female I can tell you from
experience is that that causes problems
huge problems is that when you have
sixteen or thirty or fifty or a hundred
it's triple double or triple a
personality alpha male men that are just
exploding with ego and are ultra hyper
competitive and now you have one or two
females that are now all of the sudden
in the mix it causes huge problem what
way I mean I kind of have an idea I'm
just good to know what you in them in
the way that you can imagine okay is
that you know that the competition that
exists on who can run the fastest on who
can pick up the heaviest stuff on who's
the best shot who can secure a target
the fastest that that same mentality and
attitude exists towards women as well
whether it's during the the workup cycle
or what-have-you is that the the
biological differences between men and
women are there and when you take that
that fraction of one percentage of the
highest level in terms of professional
soldiers who are at that level who are
there their job is to represent a nation
and go to other nations and defeat them
in in their back yard kick doors and
shoot people in the face and and and be
be the best at it is that that that
causes problems and even in just the
competitive nature between who's the
best shot and who's the best athlete and
everything else when you throw women in
the mix now you have a genetic component
that in my opinion again I have no doubt
there's a plenty of people that would
argue is that their there is an element
and I see this a lot in dogs too this is
one of the parallels between humans and
dogs is that men act towards women
differently especially in this country
is that we are taught most of us from
day one is that you treat them
differently is that you don't put your
hands on a woman you do certain things
for them you protect them in in the face
of danger and so if if now I I have 10
or 15 of my comrades one or two or five
or however many of which are a woman
your genetic hardwiring in my opinion it
is going to cause havoc in terms of now
when when bullets are flying and people
are getting shot and blown up and are
injured and some need to be saved
etc is that now now that throws throws
genetic hardwiring into the mix that is
never going to pan out in a positive
manner when I was in the whole Don't Ask
Don't Tell what's going on right and I
remember
we'd go to clubs and you could always
tell all of a sudden you go to all these
clubs and suddenly you go into a gay
club
sometimes the gay clubs or the best
wants to go to because you had a no
competition because you're going in a
most beautiful woman who still have to
go to get clubs because they didn't want
to be bothered right so you're going off
center markets really smart you having
fun but then one of you guys you know
it's a wait a minute this guy's at the
army what are you doing and he starts
like that was kind of a so I know you're
gay well I mean but it was Don't Ask
Don't Tell right and this was 97 and
when we got to the unit I remember my
sergeant would say don't ever be in a
room with a soldier female soldier don't
ever be in the barracks with one with
doors closed just don't do it yeah and I
said why not he would citizens I just
don't do it why not
then story came out one of the guys was
in and he's saying dude I'm telling ya I
don't do nothing to her but he went in
and he told everybody that he did take
advantage of her he raped her and in
boom he went and he did some time right
so but no one knows the truth no one was
in there to know the truth
where I'm going with this is the
following how much has a change from
Don't Ask Don't Tell to today and now
trans like I remember your end
you're something at UBC you know you
think you're from LA you're but you're
nobody we're gonna kick and they talk to
you you know they don't talk to you like
a lightweight house house how careful do
you have to be with your language today
when you're talking to new recruits from
I mean I've been out for ten years so
they're actually over 10 years I got out
in November of oh eight so just from the
people that I have kept in contact with
that you know that I value their opinion
it's it's changed pretty drastically and
that's that's part of it you know again
hazing certain language you know that
there are certain things that again this
is of course always my opinion but you
know warfare generally speaking is a
pretty brutal business and it's one
where you really can't have feelings
that have the ability to be injured or
hurt the way that that we get offended
in our society today with the littlest
thing you know from from an emotional
standpoint there's there's a level of
emotional maturity and strength that
has to be there for you to be an
effective warfighter and if it's not I
think it causes problems and I think you
know the Eddie Gallagher case as an
example I think is a good example of
where there's a newer generation of
soldiers that that have grown up under
the umbrella of political correctness
and I see it causing problems with cases
like that you've got a guy who kind of
grew up more in my generation under a
certain way and as its as he's gotten
older bordering on being a dinosaur in
the community by by their standards you
know I see that that you know that's
where a lot of those problems come from
is is that you've got a newer crop of of
guys that that just view the world
differently because they've they've
grown up in a different world it's got
it's got to be very you know I remember
there was a time where people you kinda
either wanted to be a ranger or you
wanted to be a Special Forces my body
became a delta who's got more of your
personality you know we're going to the
fifth group to be recruited to be 18
deltas and a last minute I come out he
gets my orders he goes in Vicenza the
rest is history gets picked up by Delta
and that's a life he lived he lives and
he did all this stuff all the stories
that he's got very good friend we were
at the same uniform he worked here
briefly for about six seven eight months
you know I don't know what it's like to
want to be a drill instructor today like
I don't know you know like the head you
saw my gosh what would it be to be an
instructor yeah I've been so cool to be
an instructor I don't know if I would
want to be an instructor I wouldn't I
mean I was a seal instructor the last
three and a half years I was in of
course that was you know five to the end
of Oh 8 and so even you know since then
times have changed drastically
again I don't advocate brutality for the
sake of being brutal I don't advocate
harsh standards just because you feel
like being a dick to me it's it's a
hundred percent results-driven is that
war is a nasty business you want the
best guys who are going to maximize your
your highest percentage chance of being
a successful and be able to make at home
in one piece
and and to get yourself ready for things
like that you you have to run a tight
ship and you have to have high standards
and you have to be hard on one another
you know the the pipeline the process
that exists that the selection whether
it's for Green Berets whether it's
Ranger school whether it's buds whether
it's you know selection for Delta or
green team for SEAL Team six all of
those have one common denominator and in
that you know they are a result of this
is what we need and this is the process
that we have to use to get what we need
and it's really that simple you know and
so when you start to interject societal
driven complaints or you know I would
call it you know these politically
correct norms that are becoming more and
more normal that that really you know
offset or you know really kind of fly in
the face of those traditional standards
that we have and maintain and that have
given all of these units the reputation
and the success that they've had you
know then that causes problems and
you're seeing it unfold as as we sit
here other things gonna last a long time
I don't think is gonna last a long time
here's why don't things gonna last a
long time because you know when you
think about the political correctness
comes from a certain political party
right you're not hearing it coming a lot
from maybe the Republican side you're
hearing a lot coming from a you know
left or democratic party we can't say
these got to be careful with this right
and so then you have the independent us
kinda in the middle saying just leave me
alone I'm a libertarian I want to get to
where I'll make money but don't bother
me what is starting to happen right now
is everybody's being affected by the
pull you know politically correctness
the PC movements affecting everybody so
it's tough to be a comedian today I mean
you got a Dave Chappelle that goes and
does it stand up and you know oh my gosh
you can't say something like that what
do you mean when he's given is I don't
know if you've seen it or not well I
watch it twice I couldn't believe how
amazing it was on how we explained
everything so I don't know how long this
is gonna last on the politically correct
I think eventually they're gonna be like
look we can't just do this somebody
needs to go out there and say so but
we'll see what's gonna happen what do
you think about that how long do you
think this could last I think it depends
on how how long we are
successful as a country I think that
political correctness
generally speaking or as a whole is a
direct reflection of a country
successfulness if you look at any other
countries will take your your place of
birth as an example political
correctness really doesn't exist there
at least not anywhere near in the same
realm as it does here why is that or if
take a look at the Philippines or
Indonesia or any places where their GDP
is is a fraction of what ours is and and
most of the day-to-day struggle is in
survival why don't they have it there
well because they don't have the
leverage the flexibility or frankly the
luxury to be pissed or offended by
certain words because it doesn't matter
because they're too busy worried about
just surviving and so our country has
been so successful for so long no
different than say the Roman Empire
having having a similar fate in that you
know it's the the cycle of hard hard
times create hard men you know and you
know the rest but you you get to a
certain point where it's been so easy
for us for so many generations to where
now it's inevitable so to me it's it's a
correction is coming of some sort
whether it's another country whether
it's a natural disaster whether it's a
coronavirus type of pandemic who knows
but to me the only the only way that I
really see that that political
correctness umbrella being lifted off of
our society is is a huge kick in the
nuts
frankly is is that that's what it's
going to take for people to say you know
what who cares about words I got it I
gotta feed my children I think it's
coming I think there's gonna be the huge
kick in the nuts coming very soon but by
the way the coronavirus how do you
process that to me I think it's largely
overblown you know to me I think just
like with most things in the media
you've got to two major components that
are contributing to how big of a
headline it's it's become and continues
to be which is it's an election year
overwhelmingly left run media and it's
it's a way it's one more way to further
criticize the president I wouldn't say
I'm necessarily a huge supporter or anti
I fall somewhere in the middle
but you know it's undeniable in my
opinion that that the the media is doing
whatever they can and using any excuse
that they can to try to attack them
that's part of it I think the bigger
factor is that the media uses anything
whether it's Kobe Bryant or the
coronavirus or transgender in the
military or whatever it is is that if
they can if they can find certain
stories and headlines that separate
people and piss people off and polarize
this country is that what do people do
will they watch you know and nothing
will make somebody pay attention closer
than being scared and if people are
fearing for their for their lives of
course they're gonna watch the news 25
hours a day and and try to be spoon-fed
so that they're the best prepared to
deal with something that in my opinion
you know again is is really not worth
worrying about no more than the flu the
regular flu I mean I know the mortality
rate is slightly higher but if you look
at at least from from what I've gathered
is that the people who are actually
expiring from coronavirus are in the
same health category as the people that
died or have have the mortality rate
bands of of the normal influenza so I
really don't think it's a big deal I'm
certainly not worried about it I can
tell you that what do you think needs to
happen for a president Trump to not get
reelected not reelected but not Guidry
like at this point right now even
Business Insider said investors from
from the left in New York they said if
Bernie is the nominee we're gonna go for
Trump these are Democrats yeah they're
saying if Bernie is a nominee we're
going for Trump but what do you think
needs to happen like could a coronavirus
getting out of control
hurt him getting reelected for sure it
could - the depths with which is
anybody's guess I think for sure it's a
factor I think the biggest factor
frankly is when you see the the level of
support that's been garnered for a guy
like Bernie Sanders is that it's it's
taken full advantage of what I just
mentioned is is you know a politically
correct soft and weak society that
doesn't really understand how the world
works you know that there is no such
thing as free college somebody's paying
for it just because you're not paying
for it
make it free you know in because social
media is so manipulative and because our
our education system from K through 12
and especially in the universities is so
ignorant to the way this country was
formed and more importantly why it was
formed I think is is scary and it speaks
volumes is the fact that civics classes
basically don't exist anymore and if you
ask anybody from the you know from the
age of even starting to be in the age of
reason to say in their late 20s almost
all of them were almost none of them can
accurately and correctly answer basic
tenets of our government of how bills
are passed a basic American history
basic world history and kind of why this
country exists how it got to where it is
capitalism is the reason that a guy like
Bernie even has the ability to get to
where he is which the irony is is
ridiculous with that and the fact that
most people don't pick up on that to me
is is frightening and there's enough
people at this point if you see how much
success he had in in 2016 and how close
he came you know and had the entire
Clinton machine against him had CNN was
against him in the entire DNC was
against him and he still almost beat her
out if he had had a fair shake you very
well may may have beaten her out four
years have gone by and now he's that
much stronger or I should say our
society is that much weaker and that
much more willing to hand over the keys
to their everything to a guy who
promised and promises them things that
he absolutely I mean just mathematically
cannot deliver and the fact that people
don't don't understand that that can
listen to that guy talk and say yeah
that sounds awesome to me is is
frightening why do you think he's
getting so much momentum it's for those
those exact reasons it's a lack of
civics classes it's a political correct
nature it's you think that's it okay I
absolutely do I think that that our our
success has become our own worst enemy
how much how much you that you put on
the media a lot of it not all of it I
mean it's it's a combination it's like
with most things is that you know
there's there's a multitude of factors
the media it plays a big role but it's
not the only role you know our success
technique
as an example has made our lives so easy
to wear we don't as human beings you
know for the first time in human history
in the last we'll say 30 to 50 years
maybe is the first time in thousands
tens of thousands of years where our
main day-to-day isn't based around just
surviving you know go go camping in a
national forest not even at a campground
in a national park or State Park going
to just BLM land and and then live out
of your vehicle or out of a tent for
five days a week self-contained where
you've got to purify your own water
gather your own food gather your own
wood and basically just survive and
you'll find out in a matter of hours
that none of the rest of it matters and
that's how we lived as a species for
forever until just very recently and so
the the technological advances that have
make an hour our our lives easy changes
everything it changes breeding partners
it changes how you raise your family it
changes what you give a [ __ ] about it
changes what your priorities are
when you completely alter all of those
things that are vastly different from
how they they have been genetically
ingrained in us for millennia it's a
flip of a coin as to what happens and I
think I think that's why you see the
ridiculousness that you see at this
point yeah it is ridiculous that's the
best way of putting it at is craziness
because I came here to get away from the
craziness and now you're right in a
second yeah and it's kind of like well
you know America's not a great country
to be and you don't understand what they
do over here there's a lot better places
to go to in Europe but everyone who's
saying there's a lot of places to go to
they're not moving they're staying here
yeah capitalism ultimately rain rains
King I mean we lived in Iran and we said
there are other places to go to and
people are like well then go now we did
yeah a bunch of people left because
there's many other places to go to
that's better than when we were living
there hey let me ask you
personality-wise do you did when you
went to buds and you know you you were
out and you eventually became an
instructor and so you got to different
point of views right you got the point
of view of running with your guys and
you got the point of view going and
doing different missions and assignments
and then you have the point of view of
being the instructor and kind of monitor
and everybody has seen doubt that guy
can make you land you know the game you
play or before the instructors like
hoody things are going to make it
hundred bucks says that guy's not gonna
make you discuss not gonna make you know
what have you kind of watching everybody
right like when you go to a wedding with
your friends and when we were in the
army you know you're you got drinking
buddies and you go to the wedding you
would say how long you think nine months
eighty money right and you would he's
deployed has deployed after time she's
at the club so you would sit down you
would talk about this stuff but do you
see a trend do you see a trend with who
makes a good seal and who doesn't like
do you notice any commonality because
personality-wise you have a different
personality than some of the other seals
have sat with but you do what do you see
as a commonality similar to between the
guys that make it so there's two two
points I would bring up there's actually
a third perspective that I gained in
being at a SEAL team for a number of
years and so I had the student
experience I had the instructor in
spirits but I had you know the the
opportunity I would call it to also
observe students after me that were
coming to the team and how well they did
you know and during that period and you
know it was there a difference is that
are there trends even with the new guys
and and I think it's it's human nature
to always think it was harder back when
I did it and you know the next
generation is soft there's an element of
that to everything that I'm saying
however I will say that you know the the
commonality that exists here your second
question just very plainly and simply is
that the process is what that
commonality is and that's the beauty of
the process that is buds is that what
what you don't realize as a student and
maybe they do now because the gig is up
I think much much more so than it was
when I was a student in terms of
prospective students being able to game
the system a little bit and know you
know what all the evolutions are and
what the standards are and etc but but
there's still enough of a cloaked
element to that process that exists and
just the fact that physically and
mentally it is hard I don't care who you
are you know you can't show up in good
enough shape to make it there's gonna
come a point in every individual that
shows up there that's gonna have to rely
on his mind
and so the commonality that exists
between frogmen even to this day even
even though the process in my opinion
has
has maybe wavered a little bit is that
you still have instructors that were put
through by instructors that were put
through by instructors you know going
all the way back to the early 60s you
know in the Vietnam standards that
there's still an element of that that
just gets passed down from from
instructor to student during that
process and so even now I know some guys
that I that I worked with that are now
still instructors there that are still
hard asses that are still you know doing
the over their shoulder and making sure
that that the students are earning it
you know and and thank God for that
and that the product I think is still
adequate but I it's absolutely different
you know and it's different because of
all of the the affer mentioned PC crap
sounds like you like the PC stuff a lot
you know it's like you can't of it I
thought for sure you're gonna wear like
a pro PC shirt and you came in to say
Zack yes it's blue right blue is
propecia so so let's talk about dogs so
what what what happened with the
transition of you know doing what you're
doing to now becoming a dog behavior how
did that happen two things one I grew up
a dog guy in Northern Iowa a lot of duck
duck hunting dogs labs and you know
thing bird dogs generally speaking so
it's always a huge fan of dogs growing
up I was always a dog guy more so I mean
everybody you know has a lot of people I
have dogs growing up I was really into
it
having said that as I came into the Navy
and and started to kind of you know see
in certain glimpses and different
elements of the military and how they
used dogs that's when I really became
enamored with that application of them
you know I always marveled at you know a
dog or any canines ability to use its
nose and to you know deal with
environmental challenges that that we
would have a harder time with but that
was you know an enormous ly magnified
when I actually started to see them kind
of working and what they were were
capable of and so on a deployment to
Iraq there was a group of Marines in the
area that we were in and and they had an
explosive detector dog that basically
was responsible for saving the lives of
a number of young Marines and for me
that was where everything kind of
clicked and went from just being you
know a casual you know hobby or
observation where I
looked fondly on it to where we've been
in a situation like these guys god knows
how many times and we've never had a dog
with us why not and so from that point
on which is in early oh three until as I
sit here I just have have not been able
to satiate that desire to learn more and
more about dogs specifically to their
use with apprehension and detection and
in military and police type of work so
you know it's been a you know the
majority of my adult life kind of
dedicated to really honing and mastering
and and trying to be able to educate as
best I can whether it's police canine
hand there's military handlers trainers
civilians etc and kind of putting it all
together and and you know that the
unique thing about dogs is that whether
you're talking on you know a high-speed
explosive detection dog at a federal law
enforcement or special operations unit
or all the way down to you know the the
neighbors Labradoodle it's knocking your
kids off of his bike the way that you
train those dogs and a lot of the
elements of just basic operant
conditioning and basic canine psychology
or the exact same a and B may be very
different but the way that you get there
is largely the same when you were with
the marine guys do you remember some of
the guys as names like were you close to
some of them I wasn't even there for the
actual operation they were operating in
an area that we were in and it was
basically hearsay is that hey they had
this bomb dog that that found a a
grenade booby trap clump in the entrance
of a not a cave but kind of a hole in
the wall of a berm basically and a dog
found sat on and indicated on a couple
of grenades that were booby-trapped
right there and that was it and that for
me again it was just we've been all over
this country doing all sorts of
different operations and raids and we
never had a dog with us and I and and
for me that was the slap in the face or
the light switch of saying you know
Christ why are we not using these dogs
in that same capacity had an old
acquaintance who wasn't a marine and he
was all about the training dogs he
eventually wrote a book about it he's an
actor right now there's something in
movies right now guys there was Mike but
I thought maybe there was some kind of
that would have been wild if there was
some kind of a connection there yeah so
so you're doing that now while you're
sealed did you start training
dogs then or not yet that hasn't
happened you don't see you get out on a
civilian side I did okay so at that time
you know an oh three oh four that the
start of the Iraq war
our and our meaning special operations
use of canines was extremely limited I
mean was basically non-existent and so
as we grew as a community just like any
other element that you're that you're
adding to your war fighting forces that
that takes you know years to really
develop a level of competency where when
employed overseas in actual combat it's
it's an actual asset and not a liability
it takes a long time to get to that
point and so you know I I was training
you know with Dutch shepherds and mal
and laws and German Shepherds and
different dogs in in those same or
similar capacities with either sport
clubs or you know if I could get my
hands on on you know training DVDs or
police k-9 training books which you know
there's there's been quite a few of them
out over the years or going to police
canine seminars or anything I could get
a hold of it you know I was buying dogs
that were being imported from Germany
and from Belgium and from Holland and
and training with them and working in
myself and doing a lot of things kind of
learning through the school of hard
knocks and so as I got got closer to
getting out and in that same 2004
timeframe one of the biggest reasons I
got into dogs was I got a fungal lung
infection where I lost about 40 percent
of my lung capacity I was offered a
medical retirement at the time and at
that time I had my first first child on
the way
I had no college degree and no plan of
getting out anytime soon and so with
that wrench in the gears that shifted of
saying okay well I need to figure
something out and so that coupled with
you know the the light switch moment of
overseas have already having that I was
on convalescent leave for about nine
months and during that time I was laid
up most of that time and just was
enamored by dogs and and you know
breeding theory and veterinary medicine
and conditioning and you name it and the
more I learned the more interested I was
as I got closer to being civilian is
when I was offered a position on the
west coast to be a k-9 handler and
turned it down to get out and start my
own canine company and and you know just
like joining the Navy and wanting to be
a seal I've really always taken the most
bang for your buck approach in terms of
my decision making process and as much
as I wanted to stay in and be a handler
physically I wasn't 100% convinced that
I would be able to do it and not be a
liability to the team as well as I felt
like my impact would and could be
greater felt by starting my own company
and in training lots of dogs handlers
running courses things of that nature
which which dog do you find to be the
your favorite one to train is there any
specific one for war for military if
there's one for sure the the Malinois
and the Dutch Shepherd which in my
opinion there there will be people that
you know will give me a hard time for
saying this but I view it like a
chocolate lab in a yellow lab in my
opinion it's basically the same dog
but the Malinois and the Dutch Shepherd
I think are if you're looking at just
the basic breed standard I think
percentage-wise you find more dogs in
those two breeds than any other breed
that successfully have what it takes to
do that type of work interesting yeah
when it comes down to dogs training dogs
so obviously for you you do this
professionally can any body get good at
training dogs as well anybody anybody
that's just you know and engineer
Raytheon says you know what I also want
to know how to I can train my dogs
better can I get better at it or is it
better off me Sena my dog so somebody
who's an expert to train and then it
comes back to me everybody can get
better at it okay
to me it's no different than really any
other skill set man and you could take
you know carpentry or bricklaying or
brain surgery or being a chef or what
have you is that the people that have a
natural innate ability or a knack for
that type of work whatever that type of
work is in this case dog training are
the ones who are world-class
coupled with the passion desire Drive
commitment and consistency just like
building a business or anything else is
that you know if your goal is to be a
good
trainer your genetics are going to limit
the the level at which you can you can
attain in terms of being world class or
just good or decent or great or whatever
you are driving inconsistency in desire
and and will to succeed is what's going
to allow you to cap or maximize that
genetic potential just like in every
other you know after make sense and that
thing so you know to me unquestionably I
mean the whole reason I started my
online training program was to help
people do it themselves yeah there are
some people that are probably just
better suited to hand their dog off to
somebody and have most of the training
or even all of it done even in the dogs
I deliver for say personal protection is
that I spend a lot of time educating
those new owners on how to handle the
dog how to think like the dog how to
view the world from the dogs perspective
because dogs you know that their their
mind works more like a calculator than
it does our mind what do you mean by
that we think in a language we think
about the the amount of information that
you and I have exchanged just in the
half hour or so that we've been sitting
here it's enormous human beings
overwhelmingly are verbal we think in a
language you know we conversate in the
language you dream in a language you you
think about your goals in a language
daydream etc dogs don't write well how
do they view the world well they view
the world in simple associations so a
dog's world is a plus B equals C with
everything you know whereas ours is
mostly verbal through either text or
verbal communication so understanding
that is really the the backbone of being
a successful dog trainer is that if you
don't look at the world through the
dog's eyes and think about his
interactions the way he views them no
different than you know a boss with
their employees a coach with his
athletes a teacher with their students a
parenting unit with their children is
that you've got to be able to relate to
whoever it is that you're trying to
teach train coach educate etc if you
don't what happens you you know what
you're talking about they have no idea
what you're talking about and so most
people's biggest problem is that they
don't view the world through the dog's
eyes which is again a simple Association
that's where basic psychology and very
very simple
tenets of of operant conditioning come
into into play so so to move dogs and
move people what are the similarities
and what are the differences so if I'm
trying to move a dog versus moving a
person is there some similarities in
terms of in them how not moving like
driving them motivating your to take
action there's there's almost no
difference and almost no there's no
difference in that take any of your
employees here right is that what
motivates them well human beings have it
have a currency system that equates to
everything else that they're driven for
now if you took away currency right
human humans ability to hold and possess
and value currency go back to say
bartering days well that that's exactly
what that is and so the key for the
human being in terms of training the dog
is actually very simple is that you have
to find out what motivates the dog and
then you use that to motivate the dog
now the problem is is that it's some
dogs will bite through your hand to get
to a tennis ball because they're that
driven for it some dogs you could bounce
it off of their forehead and they
wouldn't even look at it
some dogs love attention some dogs hate
it to the point where actually going
away from them as a reward
some dogs food drive is such - some
drugs food drive is such similarly is
that some act like you know that they
don't need to eat for the rest of their
life some even though they're overweight
act like they're starving to death with
what we've all seen the you know the fat
lab not picking on anybody but that you
know that'll break through a cabinet to
get to you know a box of milk bones that
he can smell in a kitchen so it's really
it's understanding you know a how that
dog views the world and then be finding
out what that dog is motivated for and
then the last component equally simple
but where people fail is that they're
lazy is it setting up the environment
for success we do the same thing with
our kids right you don't try to teach
arithmetic at Disneyworld
why not because they're distracted look
at a classroom well it's very focused
it's quiet it's organized there's rules
there's there's tenants of principles
that set those kids up for success same
thing when you're training employees to
do something you're not gonna do it at
Starbucks or at least I hope not why
because they would be distracted so with
dogs it's no different I see people you
know trying to train their dogs at dog
parks or on walks or in their living
room
there's nine kids running around in the
cap and a squirrel and whatever else and
the dogs not paying attention to him so
it's it's using the environment coupled
with whatever they're motivated for in
conjunction with understanding how they
view the world all join together for a
very basic principled system on how to
reinforce the dog for doing what you
want and how to how to use consequence
to extinguish what you don't want and
it's really that simple
all I'm thinking about is my dog that's
where I'm going well your kids are the
same way yeah you know it's it's they're
all different the way you're describing
is very interesting that some dogs just
don't I mean these two are complete
opposite personalities just like with
kids you know excuse me you know a lot
of times I mean I can tell you I have
three siblings all four of us are polar
opposites none of us are alike even
within the same litter you know just
because they're your dogs at your house
you know I'm assuming they're either
different breeds or come from different
letters at a minimum all of those things
you know the way they were raised
whatever their breed components are
their genetic traits that are passed
down from their parents you know what
what type of stressors or not the female
had while she was pregnant you know what
was what was the whelping environment
like what were the first six to eight
weeks like in terms of human interaction
versus not you know there's a multitude
of factors but the fact is is that
whether you're taking an eight week old
puppy that had all of those things you
know in its favor or to its advantage or
you're getting a four-year-old rescue
shelter dog that's an absolute train
wreck the way that you're going to
approach training that animal is exactly
the same oh you a cat guy or no I like
cheetahs like I like big cats I mean to
me I like any animal that can provide
something so small domesticated cats I
like feral cats mousers that you know
will keep keep the riffraff out of a
barn or like there's a there's a calico
cat that kind of runs runs around my dog
kennel that keeps keeps mice at bay you
know there's a lot of dog food and and
other things that entice rodents and
vermin to to come around and this Tomcat
he's pretty nasty you know it doesn't
sweat the dogs and and it keeps the
riffraff out so for me animals generally
speaking I'm not a huge fan of just
companionship
I love companionship of an animal that
also provides some
that's why I like working dogs and in
all different capacities you see so you
would never inspire to want to train
cats it depends
I might small do math I mean if like if
you were taking like I would have
trained these cats but this is the same
way I would use I would use markers and
reinforcement I'd use food with them I
probably wouldn't mess with catnip or
with toys or things of that nature I
would feed them through training big
misconception people have is that you're
gonna starve a dog the way I like to
couch it and I go over it in my online
training but as I take I use crates and
food initially just like we went through
boot camp right is that your your
conditioning a dog to behave how you
want however that is however it is that
you want the dog behaved is that you're
setting yourself up for success by
saying okay I'm gonna remove the white
noise by by using a a classroom like
environment to say here are the things I
want you to do and you do that by
waiting for them to happen marking them
and rewarding them so I would do the
same thing with a cat I would use the
cats food if I wanted to and they did
this you know during the Cold War
actually they actually used cats to to
spy on other nations meetings and in
places of of government alignment and
what-have-you and that they would they
would train cats to have listening
devices or small video recorders or a
host of other different things but they
would they would train them using using
markers and reinforcement to to go you
know spy on on Russian meetings
basically but they did the same thing in
World War two with pigeons they would
they would use pigeons to to peck at
navigation boards to steer bombs mills
the world's first smart bombs was pigeon
driven munitions in World War two very
interesting using the same mechanism how
have dogs been used obviously IEDs I
know some of them but how I what what
are some of the ways outside is what's
mean what's interesting about dogs is
that if you go back to say the first
recorded history of man combatting one
another canines were used in a lot of
the same capacities whether it's
carrying things messaging or protecting
as it dogs were used very similarly to
how they still are and when you look at
the scope of mankind and how its it's
evolved from a combative sense in terms
of
state-to-state military etc does that
you know now you've got smart bombs
you've got laser-guided munitions you've
got FLIR video and infrared and thermal
in all of these different platforms that
you know twenty-pound brains have have
developed over the years that the one
thing okay and this is the only thing
other than the human being that we still
use our canines and to me if our our
nation's tier 1 and tier 3 assets are
our nation's most elite Special
Operations Forces have dogs actually out
in front of them protecting them we
don't use anything for for anything
other than that it works you know and
the fact that our our nation's best are
deploying overseas taking canines with
them ought to tell you that there's
still a very very effective and relevant
war fighting that's in defense what you
just said right there very intense some
of the famous dogs in Wars was ships
ride ships is one weird Patton
apparently this one got a Purple Heart
and a Silver Star but they took it away
from him because they said dogs are
equipment yeah right and then you got
Nemo was a Vietnam War that this guy
killed this dog killed two via Kong's
then carios up obviously the famous one
I want to hear your thoughts and and
Lucas one with Iraq and he was the one
that was off leash just gonna rock
collecting IEDs
so Cairo did you get a chance to Union
did you get a chance to work with them
did you know the person I work with them
I know how did that story become as big
as it is today sure I I have not worked
with the dog at all I have spoken with
his handler will who actually has a book
coming out in I don't know a month or
two that's nice of you put a plug in
he's a real guy likes you that's a good
friend right there what will Chesney
yeah no ordinary dog but it's it's
basically the the chronological account
of the bin Laden raid through the dogs
eyes the way I understand I haven't read
it yet but so we'll give me a give me an
advance copy maybe but the to me that
that really highlights and frankly that
that raid in and of itself is really
what catapulted me into the national
spotlight I was just at the right place
at the right time I had just left the
West Coast multipurpose canine probe
or was on the way out basically when
that raid happened and when it did I
think the vast majority of American
citizens had just realized that special
operations were using dogs and not just
dogs but these laser-guided fur missiles
as a lot of people refer to him as and
the things that they're doing with them
blew a lot of people away and so I was
approached to do to actually do the book
as opposed to me you know approaching a
publisher I'd you know they asked me to
do it
obviously I ended up doing it and then a
60 minutes piece followed shortly after
and so all of that really just
catapulted me into a national spotlight
undeserved but just again I was the guy
at the right place the right time
forward and so it was a neat experience
and and something where it was the the
national interest in that dog in that
rate and knowing that you know using
dogs to do explosive detection as well
as apprehension and forwarding ambushes
and and you know insurgents that are
hidden in false floors or fake furniture
or things of that nature that a lot of
people just didn't realize how valuable
these dogs are for even our nation's
finest yeah that's what how many dogs do
you have yourself your dogs just mine
personally I've got three but it varies
quite a bit you don't count what kind of
dog they're all Malinois all of them
yeah so you're fully committed to them
you believe they're the best of the best
I honestly don't it's not that I that I
think they are I don't think they are
for me I I look at the dog completely
irrespective of breed and sex
interestingly an interesting dichotomy
with from very politically correct that
I can respect that I mean it's it's just
the nature of it is that you know I've
come across females that were that were
absolutely good enough where you're not
integrating them with other male dogs I
can tell you if if you had to operate in
packs of sixteen dogs I would not put
females in for the exact same reason
when it's just one Handler and one dog
there are females occasionally that you
come across that are every bit as good
as as a male dog for that application
but it's it's just the handler and the
and that's the huge difference but my
point is for me it's the dog if it's a
German Shepherd if it's a pitbull if
it's a Rottweiler adornment I don't care
what it is my test is what it is
irrespective of breed sexing in whatever
and so the dogs that pass it are the
dogs that I like are some easier to
train than others absolutely they are
just like with people some are more
cognitive some are more operant some are
quicker to learn some of them you know
have have their ability to offer
behavior which translates to me being
able to free shape a lot of the things
that I want faster is higher there are a
number of tests and batteries that you
can do to kind of gauge you know how
cognitively driven a dog is or not and
that certainly plays a role but for me
the number one trait that I look for in
a good working dog for me to own myself
is heart just like I look for in people
is that I want a dog that when when I
get in a bite suit and I pick a fight
with this dog and I make that dog
realize and understand that I'm there to
take his soul is that he he pushes back
even harder and says you know I'm gonna
take yours instead and very few dogs
actually possess that here's a question
for my baby boomer community yeah do you
believe you can teach old dogs new
tricks
if they're genetically inclined to be
taught absolutely there's there's no
what does that mean well so just like
you know we'll take MMA as an example is
that there is a physicality component
that exists that once you get to a
certain age you're not going to be as
fast as strong be able to recover as
quick etcetera but you know you know the
name Muhammad Ali or Mike Tyson or Conor
McGregor not just because of the
training right anybody can contain hard
can can work with the best people in the
planet you can put them with all the
same coaches that Tyson that Mali that
McGregor had if they don't have the
genetics to allow them to get to that
level you'll never know their name and
so with dogs it's the exact same thing
and so when I test a dog I'm looking at
their genetics I don't care if they have
tons of training no training somewhere
in the middle is that you know it's
their genetics that are gonna dictate
where I can go with that dog Mike I you
know I my wife wants a Chow Chow dog
okay sorry I heard
[Music]
I love cows I love all dogs
I gotta bust your chops little bit she's
just she just wants more dogs and so I'm
willing to you know kind of see what she
says
you know what experts will say about
this and then we got three kids an eight
to six any three-year-old right and I
hear stuff about dogs you hear about how
pit bulls are with kids or this and that
what's your experience been with pit
bulls or child shots have you had any I
have I mean I've had experience with at
this point I can't think of a breed that
I haven't had some some interaction with
whether it's helping one of you know in
an owner of a certain breed work through
some issues etc and my take again is
that you know the the breed is a very
very general and generic starting point
to me breed is like race you know is is
that while while some in some instances
there may be certain breed
characteristics that are generally
consistent throughout the breed I've
seen enough individuals both good and
bad and high and low and everything in
between of every single breed to say
that you know good dogs are where you
find them and it's the individual that's
gonna dictate you know where your right
and left flank is in terms of what you
can do or not do with them what I would
say is that irrespective of breeds that
you know if you're going to a breeder or
a shelter or whatever one of the lessons
actually teach on my online training is
how to evaluate a dog to me that's
that's instrumental it's no different
than you know if you're looking to hire
somebody like you're not gonna say oh
it's a black male and he's this age so
yeah you're you're the guy know you're
gonna interview them you're gonna see
what a skillset is and so to me how do
you never you dog do well very similarly
is that just like I was talking about
you want to look at what they're
motivated by you gotta find dr. Dolittle
like I got it that's really all you have
to do yeah yeah I mean the reality of
pluck team dog got pennant team dog got
Petco head you were saying I mean it's
so it's it's a series of similar tests
no different than an interview is that
you have to look at you know what do I
want out of a dog right and everybody's
situation scenario family dynamic is
going to be different if you're a 96
year old slightly built female that you
know needs a walker
a nine-month-old hundred and forty pound
Great Danes probably not your best bet
you know justjust as one staring you in
the face you know you know thing but but
unfortunately a lot of people they walk
through a shelter and I feel bad for
that dog where that dog is cute let's
pull that one out to me you're not
you're not doing you or the dog any
favors by adopting the wrong dog in a
and this is something I catch hell for
on a regular basis is that you know the
the adopt don't shop mentality while
sounds great and if you don't really
think about it makes a lot of sense I
would just ask anybody who revels in
that mentality to stop and think for a
second is that ask yourself are our
shelters underfunded no they're the best
funded and most well-equipped of any
time in our society because most people
don't I don't know that they are really
there they're everywhere and and they're
full why are they full most people think
it's because not enough people are
spaying and neutering their dogs again
my perspective having spent a couple of
decades now seeing dogs in shelters
pulling some of them out and actually
training them in and them ultimately
winding up in our airports for TSA
sniffing bombs do it dogs that I pulled
out of shelters that were of that
caliber can't take any dog that does
that but my point is is that for all of
the people that say be a responsible dog
owner and spay or neuter your pet my
twist on that is that if you as a
prospective dog owner have that little
ability to control your animal from
breeding you should not have an animal
you shouldn't have a dog period I would
go with maybe a goldfish or something
that's way easier to contain than a dog
because if you can't keep them from
having puppies you've got no business
teaching them how to heal teaching them
how to not not kids over steal food out
of the trash etc like that that's one of
the most basic tenants of dog ownership
is don't let them breed right and so the
the reality of the overpopulation or the
filling of shelters that exists is
primarily in in the people that are
breeding dogs at that lower end of the
spectrum right that are the couple
hundred dollar craigslist or whatever
you know type of type of environment
where people are buying them whether
it's out of a shelter or out of the
paper is that if everybody was educated
enough to be able to evaluate dogs and
say no you know yeah it's a cute puppy
it's got shitty nerves it's scared of
its own shadow it won't eat right and
and it's shivering in the corner I'm not
buying it well guess what now your
demand doesn't exist right because
everybody and I and I get that you know
that the road to hell is paved in good
intentions everybody's heart is in the
right place they see you know that the
Shivering pit bull in the corner and
they want to save that dog I'm not
saying necessarily do or don't do that
what I am saying is that if we raise our
standards as a society then then when as
soon as people stop spending two three
five hundred dollars on newspaper
classified Craigslist ad pets the demand
for them goes away people will stop
breeding them the only reason people are
breeding them is because people are
buying them it's that way with drugs
with guns with anything yeah and so to
me it's a paradigm shift the other thing
to keep in mind is that shelters god
bless them do you really think it's in
their best interest to be empty no think
about that for a minute if you run a
shelter and you've got five staff and
you have no dogs in your shelter what
are you out of a job what are you also
out of funding it's also I think it
seems to be lost on most people that
when you go to a shelter how many of
those dogs are free almost none of them
you know it's usually a few hundred
dollars between a spay and neuter fee
and an adoption fee and a processing fee
and a bla-bla-bla fee is that you know
ultimately what are you doing well
you're you're still spending money on
subpar dogs that are now being fueled by
these these backyard poor standard
breeders that are filling shelters that
are filling backyards not adhering to
basic tenets of breeding practice and
theory and insulin genetic selectivity
that if more people did that and more of
the consumer was better educated to be
able to identify know that I want
nothing to do with that dog then then
that problem it would suck for you know
a few years but those tides would turn
if people would be would be much more
staunch advocates for good genetic
breeding practices vice tugging on the
heartstrings and just
grabbing whatever dog needs to be saved
define suck for a few years what does
that mean because to do that some of
these dogs if they don't have a foam you
home you got to do something to him
right and so you would have an a a
bubble burst just like say the housing
market in the late 2000s is that you
know there would there would be an
excess of dogs that nobody knows what to
do with you know but but again let's say
you know the happy medium is you have no
kill shelters that you know you just
house them but if you have educated
people that say this dog has no business
being adopted out does that mean that
you kill them no not necessarily but
what it means is that they don't get
adopted out because if they don't get
adopted out now there's not room for
something to take their place and just
continue that shitty vicious cycle that
exists and continues I mean this number
should scare everybody 3.3 million dogs
are surrendered to shelters every single
year why is that all the things I just
talked about about 8.3 million 3.5
thousand on average are euthanized every
year which breaks down to over two
thousand dogs every day all right two
thousand dogs every day are euthanized
and just in this country alone well if
the if the Bob Barker don't forget to
spay and neuter your pets at the end of
price is right and the adopt don't shop
campaigns that flood Facebook on
national pet day etc and and the
breeders who get chastised for having
you know selectivity and in their in
their breeding practices if all of those
things didn't happen you wouldn't you
wouldn't have these problems again in my
opinion is that you you've got to raise
the standard how big is a dog I have
friends that are breeding dogs and they
make this ammonia but how big is the dog
breeding business well it depends on on
what you're breeding for I mean I do
very little breeding because it's a
terrible business to get into if you're
doing it right which it's a terrible
business to get into if you're doing it
right right because when likes let's say
I find you know male a and and female B
that are both consummate textbook
examples of what I'm trying to reproduce
and I will say this is that from my
perspective if you are breeding for dog
breeding dogs for anything other than
those two things is that this is a
consummate perfect example of what the
breed standard is and should be you
should not be breeding those dogs that's
that's my my philosophy on it even when
I do that let's say there's a litter of
eight dogs is that there's gonna be a
few of them that are really nice there's
gonna be a few of them are that are
average and there's gonna be a few of
them that are a little below average not
always sometimes maybe most of them are
great sometimes most of them are less
than great my point is is that to to be
able to breed those dogs and spend the
time that you have to spend with them to
make them maximize their genetic
potential which is in separating them
right as an example a lot of people
leave puppies with their mom and
together until they're eight weeks old
why because it's easy a lot of people
justify it by saying well it's what
nature intended
etc etc well it is if they were left in
that environment well here's the the
kicker is that they're not right is that
there though every one of those dogs
ultimate goal is going to be to either
be with a family or with an individual
human being right and so my philosophy
which which has helped me out
tremendously in terms of producing nice
dogs is taking that that each of those
individual puppies and separating them
from their mom and from their litter
mates far sooner than eight weeks I want
to get them paired up with a human being
or several human beings as fast as
possible so they fall into that routine
the longer you leave them with their
litter mates and their mom the harder it
is to pull them when they're older and
and the more trouble you're gonna have
in terms of exposing them to
environmental factors that may sketch a
dog a little bit loud noises Home Depot
it's how big is the business those are
people making money is there people
making real money not not in my opinion
not real money like a million out of you
right now I'm not making that kind of
money no six figures yes mmm there's
probably a few there's probably a few
breeders that have the ability to make
six-figure businesses but it's I would
say it's very very few what's the bet
what what what do people what does a
market pay the most for from I mean I'm
not really in that market but from what
gather just based off of clients that
have problems it's a lot of the designer
breeds it's certain colors of say French
bulldogs Goldendoodles all of the mix
you know the the cockapoos that you know
whatever it's the the mixing of breeds
and creating these fad designer breeds I
think is a big problem but then you take
any of the more popular breeds whether
it's labs Rottweilers pitbulls whatever
each of them kind of have their their
niche and society that exists that that
fuels that demand for for backyard
breeders and then sub sub breeding
practices got it on a sidenote you know
these dogs when they come back you know
I've read multiple articles that even
dogs can sometimes experience PTSD
absolutely what does that look like when
dogs are experiencing again it's very
similar to the the manifestation that
exists in human beings
the key component just like I was
talking about earlier it's a simple
Association right so with human beings
we have the ability to to use logic and
reason to try to understand or be
bothered by what what happened to us in
combat or in a traumatic environment
with dogs they're making that simple
Association right so let's say a dog is
is averse to gunfire because it's been
you know it's making that a plus B equal
see association with gunfire you know
being in an armored personnel carrier a
plus you know gunfire B equals C chaotic
stressful environment for an extended
period of time where my nerves are shot
and I shut down right and then the next
night you go out you're in an armored
personnel you know a gunfire B I shut
down C night after night after night and
so now the presence of a it may be an
armored personnel carrier just rolling
up and the dogs start shivering and
blows it's saying lines and shuts down
it's you know when a plus B equals C
enough that the mere presence of a
equals the anticipation of C and so the
good news with that is that you can use
that same logic of now replacing those
with something positive so let's say
it's gunfire which is very common over
helicopter noises so now I'm going to
pair playing tug or ball or feeding or
playing fetch or something like that
with gunfire but it'll be like a 22
caliber from you know six hundred yards
away where you barely hear
and that that is just occasionally
present while we're playing toddler
playing ball or experiencing positive
things and then you just slowly
stair-step but think of it like like a
piggy bank you got positive and negative
coins and if you've got 400 negative
coins as it relates to gunfire you want
to put five or six hundred as it relates
to something else it makes sense even
now I'm starting to realize why one of
my shih tzus has PTSD due to my oldest
son it's very obvious you know my oldest
son is not stopped with them you know
and I see his reaction to it are you a
religious man by the way I am NOT you're
not a religious not do you think all
dogs go to heaven I think that I believe
in the Rainbow Bridge I'll call it that
I I do believe that or I guess I would
I'd say I'm cautiously optimistic that
dogs go wherever any of us go if there
is such a thing so if there is such a
thing as I haven't you think it's filled
with dogs god I hope so I don't know if
cats are gonna make it though I think
the cool ones will to finish up with a
couple serious topics here's I'm from
Iran obviously you had some experience
being over there as well what are your
thoughts you know what are your thoughts
with what's going on there well how bad
could it be and what needs to happen I
guess this would be my last question on
that topic is how bad is it really and
what needs to happen for the Middle East
to kind of calm down yeah and for there
to be less friction I think I think
similarly with corona or any other
headline I don't think it's as bad as
it's made out to be yeah I don't that's
not the paint a picture of it being a
picnic but I think in some ways it gets
overhyped especially when you have a far
left media and a right-wing president
anything he does or doesn't do gets
ostracized and I think further in flames
or fans the flames of that conflict
having said that you know it's hard for
me as a as a former military member and
this may surprise a lot of people but
it's hard for me not to put myself you
know I do so much projecting with dogs
is that I find myself doing the same
thing with with other nations other
militaries and you know I'm not going to
be naive or deny
I the fact that if Iran decided to build
an Air Force Base in Mexico that we
wouldn't have some heartburn about that
or if China had a you know a an aircraft
carrier group 4045 miles off the coast
of San Francisco hanging out that we
wouldn't you know get our panties and a
lot over it you know to me there there's
obviously an element of you know trying
to strike a balance of having a presence
in a region where it seems like there's
a necessary level of involvement on the
same token you know to me warfare again
when I reduce it down to the most simple
equation which I am a firm believer that
some of our world's most complex
problems actually require them the
simplest of solutions and I look at
foreign policy no different than a bar
fight right is that you walk into a
Chili's and and the [ __ ] has hit the fan
in there and you've got around and in
every country in the Middle East and in
America everybody's fighting well when
you walk in there I don't care what you
do right I don't care if you get
involved you're gonna piss somebody off
if you don't get involved you're gonna
piss somebody off if you take this
person's side you're gonna piss the
opponent off you know so that there's
there's no way to get involved in
foreign policy militarily without having
that ripple effect that we that we
learned a painful lesson as did Russia
in Afghanistan in the eighties 70s and
80s is that you cannot have a presence
somewhere without it pissing somebody
off that's the reason al-qaeda exists
you know because of Kuwait a very good
point you know so to me it I look at it
very simply is that if we're going to
decide to step into that bar and I'm not
saying don't step into what I'm just
going to say if we decide to step into
it is that it better be all in it better
be absolutely necessary to maintain our
way of life and our standard of American
security and when you go in there there
are no rules a lot of people don't like
hearing that I've fully subscribed to
the civil war to come say Sherman
mentality of you make it so god-awful
that the other side wants to stop
fighting because you've made it it's so
miserable on them
you subscribe to that my absolutely do
it but there's a caveat and it's what I
just mentioned is that you don't step
into that unless it's absolutely
necessary if it's absolutely necessary
and we as a country are all behind it
and say yes we have to get involved here
then you go there and you a and you
leave it to your military which that's
what their job is is to go over there
and absolutely wreck shop and and you
know whatever it is you know whether
it's destroying an enemy wiping a
certain population you know off the plan
really well I quite like that that that
far if necessary I mean to me if we're
gonna involve our troops you know
otherwise you're gonna see exactly what
you've seen right as you see I mean
let's let's take Afghanistan as an
example what what have we really gained
twenty years later you know now we're
trying to meddle in a peace deal with
the Taliban which is you know like
licking a Chinese doorknob in terms of
safety right now like it's it's fragile
at best it's it's dicey it's it's gas
food or it's gas station sushi right
you're not you're not you know it's it's
not in your favor that it's gonna pan
out right so we're we're still messing
with it and if you look at you know
hills that were taken and fobs that were
secured and in this region that we
overrun and then gave it back and same
thing in Iraq you know and I don't look
at any of my friends I've got a lot of
them that have lost their lives I don't
look at at their their lives in vain I
view it very simply is that we all
volunteered to you know write a blank
check up to and including our life
payable to the United States government
for them to use us in the way that they
see best fit and that's honorable you
know and and it doesn't matter how they
use you you do the best to your ability
and how they use you as is their
business it's the country's business you
know we all we all served our purpose
and we did what we did because we wanted
to and so you know I think that's
honorable and and I don't I don't view
any of the deaths in vain but I would
also say is that to prevent you know
further people from dying for reasons
that are hard to really explain as to as
to why it was necessary and and how its
validated is that you know you've got to
look at things of saying okay if we
really need to go there then you do
whatever you have to to to keep the
other side from fighting I mean we did
it in World War
- was that the right call I don't know
you know I wasn't alive then it's been
long enough to where I'm not privy to
the information that that you know gave
gave our government the the
decision-making process to say yes we're
going to drop you know these these types
of munitions on Hiroshima and Nagasaki
but what did it do well it stopped the
war that fast
you know right decision that we make the
right decision with that and like I said
I don't know you know not not having
been alive then and not being privy to
to what it was like then and and you
know sitting in on intelligence
briefings where where I'm being told
here are all the Front's and and here's
the supply routes and here's our
casualties and here's where our finances
are and here's where our country I mean
I I don't know all of those things let
me ask you to do what for the way you
process issues when do you think would
make sense for America to use it - again
because that that's not been done for a
while yeah what what what does another
nation go to push the buttons or cross
the line for us to say that acceptable
based on your opinion so in based on my
opinion I would say a a level of threat
with which you can undeniably prove that
there is a level of existential threat
to the safety and security of our our
homeland you know if you can say yes
absolutely if we don't do this our
nation will fall to me that justifies it
that's that's really the only
circumstance that I can come up at it
yeah I think most people would agree
with that if you're saying to get to
that point well and so that you know to
bring it back to my you only get
involved if necessary there's a lot of
things the Sherman Sherman principle
you're talk right is that is that that's
in our that's in our country is if we
don't defeat these guys our way of life
disappears and so he did what he had our
way of life disappears if we don't
defeat these guys right God who is the
biggest threat we have today based on
you your opinion what do you think it is
us 100 percent us I think we we will
will screw ourselves over far before
anybody else does Wow
in which way in the way that I've been
harping on interest on that anything
outside of that or not you know I mean
you
you divided you stand united you know
United you stand divided you fall is
that that that mentality is is far more
toxic poisonous and dangerous than than
any outside threat look at 9/11 you know
nine twelve we were we were undefeatable
you know that's whisked away over time
but that level of attack on us does what
well it unites everybody where there was
not a member sir I don't push on the pin
everybody was 100% ready to go just rip
the heads on the thing we knew no no the
crisis like that I mean you need you
think man needs it to come you know you
know how sometimes like if I know you're
not a religious man but you think God
created the system and a way where you
lose a father than a mother for you to
realize the value of life like do you
think we almost need a crisis to realize
how lucky we are to live in a nation
like this for sure I think there's an
element of suffering required suffering
that is built into the human condition
that you know when I look at some of the
most successful people in the world are
also some of the most miserable people
in the world because they they lack
challenge I think just like uber
successful people just like our country
is is that if you're successful and
comfortable enough long enough you get
complacent to where you know you you
fail to find purpose and I think you
know that's one of the most dangerous
mindsets that a human being can possess
is when they lack purpose and they're
comfortable for full disclosure you're
not talking about the most successful
people are the most miserable it's
people that are no longer driving for
purpose bigger than them that's kind of
what you're trying to say yeah but
you're not just saying somebody that's
unknown or a billionaire not necessarily
but you know I mean to me when you see a
guy like say Chris Cornell you know the
the lead singer of Soundgarden hanging
himself you know Robin Williams or you
know obviously there's some troubles
there but I think if you if you open it
up to a more 30,000 foot view on just
this country our country is is the most
successful wealthy technologically
advanced and comfortable it's ever been
in the history of ourselves
what are we also the most depressed the
most ADHD ridden the most pain and pain
narcotic and an anxiety medication
addicted that we've ever
and arguably the most divided and
miserable we've ever been as a country I
don't think that's an accident I think
it's a direct correlation of again the
technological advances and that how that
translates to dogs is that you know
we've got access to the most information
as it relates to dog training that we
ever have via the internet right even
with that you know there there are more
people struggling with their dogs now
than ever before
because there there is a disconnect from
nature and training a dog is is a
borderline primal experience and so it
did I think it all kind of just fits
together I got a man I really enjoyed
this well I I didn't I I didn't know
what to expect when you thought it was
gonna suck
no because the way you speak man when
you're speaking your tone I'm like this
this could be but I tell you're a
ridiculous storyteller and you're the
kind of guy that if I was a I would have
loved to have served with you because
you have a side of your humor is
ridiculous yes I was is it the Yogi
Berra sense senior you're like yeah I
almost have to be smart to understand it
because there's like a three-second
delay you have a little bit of death I
mean I pride myself on on more on the
highbrow side than the low but I
appreciate that it's very obvious you're
very sensitive are you an April baby or
once your birthday in July July what no
towards the end
leo Emily or Leo huh interesting
your why rank very are you big reader or
no I am very interesting okay again I
really enjoyed it going back to a team
dog dot pet any information on the on
what you do with dog behavior they can
find it on they can you tell us a little
bit about that website what I'm gonna
find when I go sure it's so it's it's as
simple as I can make it in terms of you
know expounding on the the tenets and
principles that I've spoken about as it
relates to dog training and just giving
you video representations of all of the
things that I'm talking about I have a
book called team dog as well that you
know I had enough people read it and
actually asked if I would make videos
and start a YouTube channel whatever so
I started a an online training it's $99
for unlimited access for a year and
that's it and i and i get in there every
monday morning and i answer questions in
in forums i interact with people every
week very cool so it's it's i wanted to
make it very affordable
for your average everyday dog owner so
that we could at least try to get rid of
that 3.3 million number and you know
between my philosophy on breeding and
raising that criteria in conjunction
with trying to educate dog owners how to
how to evaluate how to train their
existing dog and live a little more
cohesively you know I wasn't looking to
retire on it I just I wanted it to be
worth it for people to do much much much
respect to human you look like I say I
know when I meet somebody that's sincere
you are so sincere you're you're a man
on a mission with what you believe in
with your dog's the man is a three-time
New York Times best seller for reason
we're gonna put the links to all your
books he didn't ask me to do it because
he said let's just talk about what he's
doing with the courses well we put the
links at the top would be the link to
the website that he has we'll put the
links below as well for his books and
how to get a hold of with that being
said Mike thank you so much for coming
out I guess I really enjoyed the
brothers it looks great thank you for
having me so we covered so many
different topics and this one woman in
the navy seal politically correctness
dogs Trump coronavirus so many different
topics if you enjoyed this interview I
got two other videos I want you to watch
one of them is with General Spaulding
when he broke down the effects and
consequences of five G if you've never
watched this you gotta watch this and if
you haven't watch Jordan Peterson's
interview I did I wants a year and a
half ago we talked about political
correctness click on this one here as
well and if you've not subscribed to the
channel please do so thanks for watching
everybody take care bye bye
[Music]